hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Fran bow I did want
to say sorry very sorry for the delay in
this video or in this game I've been on
vacation and I didn't have my save file
and I didn't want to play through the
entire game again I do intend to finish
this very very soon and I'm sorry for
all the delays so what I need to do is I
need to get to harvest time the basket
seems to be in good shape that's good
can I take the basket what I don't think
I can anyway what I need currently is a
lemon as far as I remember and this guy
doesn't seem to be doing anything would
you like to join me and waiting let's
see that would be fun but I have to find
my way home
oh I'm never gonna be able to remember
all the voices that I was putting to all
these characters okay so let me real
quick I need to get a grasp on exactly
what I'm doing and where I'm going so
give me a few minutes to like re settle
myself into the game and I'll get back
to you in just a moment
ah haha okay that's what I thought okay
what I did is I cut a hole in the basket
and that means that the basket now can't
hold all the lemons I'm such a sneaky
little girl okay so now I can't hold all
the lemons and when he he's gonna drop
one yes I have a lemon I forget what I
need a lemon for but now that I have a
lemon I think I'll keep it so I've got
lemon and a feather from pelant hrus
blonde Tris was that his name falling
into the sky I can't wait to do Apple on
Drew's voice again um but that's like
the only voice said I think I'm gonna be
able to remember this is to get in here
did you need to know you needed like a
card or something what I did lemon for I
don't know what a special ticket is with
a special ticket a lemon why did I need
lemon I don't remember did you need a
lemon ah okay I'll be right back again
oh look kitty get in the boat we're
going for a ride oh okay good
where are we going how are we gonna get
anywhere oh cool woohoo isn't this fun
kitty is the best kitty
yay oh-oh-oh Fran this is where we were
before
I fixed the bridge to get your purse Wow
kitty you're very clever I hope we find
my things okay kitty let's go I really
do think that after I get out of this
area oh now I don't have to be naked
anymore
kitty I can't find my pills maybe the
pills are not here maybe you lost them
well they weren't doing me any good
anyways maybe they will appear someday
let's keep going now
okay find the clothes come to me your
one and only where huh
use with me am I not supposed to wear
these examine my beautiful clothes they
smell fine I don't need to wash them I
didn't think that you did why Dean oh I
guess you can't go to the human world
completely naked that would be
inappropriate was I'm not able to do the
time change over there I guess it's too
far away from the clock so I guess that
would make sense but what happens if I
do this Hey
Oh Oh can't get anywhere I'm stuck I
can't sail on ice all righty then so is
there any reason to change this here
huh I have no idea I mean if I go over
here I change it no I guess that guy
isn't voting at the moment I guess I can
get that fishing pole maybe that might
help can I get that see yes okay a
fishing rod it seems to be broken so
somebody should be able to repair this I
still have a coin so maybe someone else
can take the coin from me and also I got
to remember the library was only open
during hey wait a minute here
that's not something good conclusive
friend I have the one thing you desire I
have what you're looking for Oh mom I
don't think that's my mama my beloved
daughter come closer let him feel you
mommy I'm scared there's nothing to be
afraid of you have to come closer friend
I wanna kiss you but you can't be my
mother she's dead you have to come
closer now if you don't the big monster
will come and get you
no you are not my mommy leave me alone
my darling the big monster will come and
get you he will come and get you
he will come and get you
I don't know why I got a Southern drawl
[ __ ] you're scaring me mommy stop it
please my goodness that's not good at
all thanks for disappearing in the giant
cloud of blood that was awfully
reassuring I'm so happy that all
happened okay so I got a fishing pole
but my understanding is that in the
winter this guy is anybody around hello
I thought one of the clues would have
been about coal or something does this
guy just hear all the time
maybe let me see if I can give this in
repair this sir look I found a fishing
rod but it's broken can you help me Mara
let me see I don't remember this guy's
work something's missing have you seen
the hook that goes with this rod huh you
just said the exact same thing someone
else back did wails someone else did
back in the hospital
oh really
who what hospital the Oswald asylum sir
the nurse when I broke the curtain oh I
have no idea what you're talking about
you'll class rings well let's forget
about it it probably doesn't mean
anything that all my memories are
blurring together and whatever yes let's
do it if you give me one coin I'll give
you half look half a hook
give me two coins you'll get it into our
can hook I don't need half a hook I need
the whole thing the whole thing will
copy
greenhorn wait a minute wait a minute
sense 1 what what huh Oh
sir you're complicated I'll bring your
coins soon but I got a whole bunch of
coins from the dude here are your three
coins sir
I guess maybe wonderful thank you he's
your hook it was done already i swindled
your ass and now you can't go away hey I
got a hook I think ok thank you sir it's
perfect I have to GU nelq goodbye ok so
if I go back to the lake in the middle
of winter if I recall there was it now I
don't need your look at that I'm
perfectly fine thank you
so if I go over here in the middle
winter if I recall there's a little
crack in the ice so if I combine these
two oh no I need strong string if I
recall there was like a string salesman
just over yonder way didn't know that's
what I need to do sir I need your thread
good thread in cloth to make stuff and
boat hands bot ends okay it's a good day
for fabric and thread I am at your
service
okay so can I get a thread for them I'm
clever enough to find another solution
it's right in front of my face I don't
need it I do need I need thread it's got
to be something else over here then so
if there's nothing there I mean I've
been here throughout all the seasons
right I don't know if I've come down
this way during winter cuz that could
mean that there's something interesting
about okay so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna go up to I'm gonna go up to the
library because I remember that the
library was only open during a certain
season so if I go there and also what is
with this what's with the big open
staircase there it seems like that would
be a problem okay
hey thanks lady there you have the
password oh no what password the library
password of course you must have it to
come inside who knows the password how
am I supposed to know there was bass
word the great wizard of course he knows
everything
oh all right then I'll go to the great
wizard to get the password for the
library and then I'll be able to go
exactly where I need to go Oh sir Matt
wait what the hell happened to that guy
did he turn into a snowman has he been
sitting there for so long he turned into
snow man you having fun I don't know if
fun could be dead trigger 2 to a snowman
okay so there's got to be something else
over this way up on the mountaintops
where the man who's crazy lives do you
know the password to the library hello
can you explain the riddles again I
forgot what to do I know the riddles
Oh
ah okay all right so I needed to show
the fishing rod uh come on I knew this I
wandered through the whole game I knew
this is what I was supposed to do oh man
quite a lot is that good oh man
okay I forgot to think about the prizes
you never sold anything before I'm a
terrible terrible salesman you know what
you're gonna have it I hope it makes you
happy I mean my children aren't gonna
get fed tonight what does that matter to
me have it
Billu okay thank you mister I'll just
settle some prices and sell something
soon okay so now that I got that I can
combine that with this and combine that
with this Lada bing bada boom now
confession frozen river which is in
pretty sure was part of what our
supposed to do I should have known that
a long time ago well I didn't use it on
the correct thing I knew what I was
supposed to do it just didn't work out
that way
okay so now I take this use it on that
no ah okay here okay got it there this
here hey I got a fish wow that is a
weird expression on my tree face okay
I'm very sorry sorry about what yeah if
it's dead now so what could I do with
the fish I can give it to my kitty cat I
don't know what to do with the fish what
do I do with a fish who'd want a fish oh
that's oh never mind that's part of the
clue duh uh flow flow cold-blooded son
let your body dance through the rising
stream that's a fish okay so the last
thing I need is a piece of coal I'm
almost a hundred percent positive
they're talking about coal so I just got
to find the coal I can tear this gotta
figure out how to get coal from this guy
if I show him the thing okay so I feel
really bad about it but I was wandering
around for a long time I had to look up
a walkthrough
and the walkthrough I would I thought I
was right I fight it said cold as stone
I'm cold as I am but if you use me I'll
be burning hard it's referring to my
matchbox like that's what it was like
duh of course it would be so now I know
what I need to do I have all that I need
and let's see it's like number one goes
top so matches top lemon right fish okay
matches lemon fish yadda yadda yadda
okay so the matches go up top lemon goes
right the fish goes bottom and then the
feather goes left got it
there we go so yeah I did it thanks Bob
Highsmith victory I smell delicious
victory this is not his voice I can't
even remember congratulations thank you
sir I'm ready
let's bring the stones back yes we'll
start with the fire
oh all right then Oh didn't you like my
demonstration of magic Karim has
awakened caught em is alive
um whose cotrim don't ask little girl on
the top of a mountain he'll be waiting
for you yes my lovely wizard hat bring
it to me I'm weird uh your your hat yes
a stone - hiding in my wizard tools
namely my hat that's why I can't
remember a thing but now I am
remembering go to the top of the
mountain and find cotrim and come back
when you have the hats and we can do
other things okay good bye get out of
here now I'm very old all right sir I'll
bring you your hat yep friggin weirdo
kitty I see you eyeballing that fish
don't even try already then I'm gonna go
say hi to cotrim who's apparently a
talking Mountain pretty cool like a
gasps hello Oh you ever had oh okay hi
Oh who dares to wake me up who I'm Fran
oh my goodness you're alive sorry to
bother you talking mountain I'm Fran
Fran happy I don't know what I mean oh
that was that the boy so soon for thee
huh I can't remember at this point I
don't know what that means
well I don't really know what it means
it's just my name oh all right well
mines coal tram do you want to know why
sure tell me God Rama's born in heaven I
used to be a star and because I was born
in space it's very logical huh what oh
wow I've never met a star in person I
don't think I ever will not that I'm
doubting you but I'm doubting you nice
to meet you too Fran so I bring you here
I need the Hat
I need hat sir the hat above your head
mmm I can't do that I'm divorced huh
what do you mean divorced I just need
the hat sir it's very important I can't
if I give you the hat the entire land
Mustafa you have to find another way to
get home the king told me there's no
other way please help me I told you I
can't my wife left me she was the one
cover in my top this doesn't make any
sense at all if I take off the hat my
Magna will erupt
and kill everyone including you uh what
happened I don't want that I don't think
I want to know this story she she
decided it was time for her to start a
Rhode Island so she broke up with me
mm-hmm
ask her why even though I told you the
exact reason in my previous intense um
no good huh
Oh so now she's her own Island huh do
you know where she is I think she's on
the water otherwise I would very
strongly feel her presence but I don't
know huh okay I'm just gonna back away
slowly while this mountain cries I'll go
and see if I can find her then you give
me the hand only if she comes back
otherwise you know what could happen
I'll blow my top not in a weird way
don't be weird about that can I put
something else on you're good sir like a
rock or something no and don't you dare
you fill it with polyp pull pull pull
ocean don't poop don't feel with poop
either
no I like this hat I'm beginning to
think that this mountain is just being
sassy with me okay BRB alrighty
oh I think I know where I need to go
okay I know you are alone let me be your
mommy let me feed you come to my side
and you will have many new friends to
play with I know I want you as my mommy
you creepy creepy whatever you are
you're very scary and I don't like you
Fran were you talking to huh the woman
stand up ah never mind kitty it's
nothing only horrible monstrosity that I
should probably keep you in the loop
about probably being Mutual best
interests okay so I need to go steal a
boat and then go swim swimming over the
island I was wondering why there was
this weird Island huh that's not kiddie
being scared there for a second hello
hello hello hello miss wake up I have a
message for you
hello will poo oh hello a messenger what
a good day yes miss I'm a messenger of
love
love oh but you're not in pink oh okay I
used to have human skin though it's
almost pink man what does the messenger
of love have something to share yes of
course I'm here in the name of love to
bring you back to your husband maybe
he's a volcano no he made me very sad
nobody has the right to make me sad Oh
what did he do I gotta stop doing that
voice caramel my throat he was so hot
and I felt that but lately he was cold
and boring so I live felt left aside I
cried so many times on top of his head
like a weirdo he used to grow a
beautiful red flower just for me to show
his love for me
nothing came up I do you know what I am
the one protecting him all the time so I
want some credit for that that's all but
miss if I can find that flower for you
would you come back oh I guess my love
is very superficial small tokens mean
the world to me for some reason but I
have no hope because I'm the ruler of my
own Island now okay I'll go and see if I
can find the red flower do you know
where it grows always at the bottom it's
very different from all other flowers
bottom of why my husband's bottom of
course oh it's a bud flower a lovely
rosebud for you oh boy that's just silly
that's just the silliest silly I've ever
heard in my entire life why do I have to
subject myself to picking a flower from
her husband's bottom and there it is
wouldn't you know this must be lose our
can I get it ha ha it's like warm love
frankly I don't want to know what warm
love feels like this was the most
useless task I've ever had in my life
going to find a flower for a freakin
mountaintop to fix their divorce this is
so weird and inner spliced with random
moments of terror great look the red
flower oh thank you so much I'll live
steadily go back to my husband now thank
you miss we should go back to your
husband he really misses you I'll see
you there in winter time how here a
piece Oh
I guess I shouldn't have asked any
questions
well this was an adventure that was so
silly that was the weirdest all right
okay let's get to winter shall we
hahaha oh hey how's it going
thank you so much I'll never forget what
you've done for us double my darling
climb on to my top I don't think I want
to be here for this oh god oh god no no
oh god ah ah okay all right
that was boo that was something anyway
thank thank you okay
all right
I think I'm scarred for life how about
you guys I think I'm never gonna sleep
again all right okay I was more
disturbing than everything I've seen the
entire game up until this point huh oh
all right here's your hat sir I forget
his voice already oh my hat I feel the
knowledge flowing through my body but
not my brain I feel happy I think that's
great sir what's next a gift from the
soil the fruit thingy
Francesc assalamu Halawa the creation of
selective random elements so we can eat
a beautiful isn't it
hehehe yes it's incredible I have no
idea what you're talking about
yes the fruit is talking to me now it's
saying that you need to give me all of
your money
maybe my book of knowledge it's in the
library but but beware the book may be
hiding so you have to be persistent and
patient I don't know what that means sir
my underwears riding up that's why I'm
shifting good all good library there's a
password let me think
cranberries the password is your basic
senses are easily manipulated shut them
down before learning okay that's weird
password odd yes don't dad I don't just
duck you start I don't want a doggy
all right it's fun to learn stay in
school kids don't do drugs cuz you'll
end up in this world don't just pop
random toast from bottle you will turn
into Fran bow you'll see nightmares your
entire life
and bad news all around okay good bye
good bye good bye
why do you remember Fran you are a
murderer you are a naughty little girl
nutty girls must be punished
oh oh hi do as I say he was a dear
friend jump fine rats it's so cam oh I I
didn't want to kill them I didn't want
to oh my dear don't listen to those evil
things you're strong let them out of
your head my dear my crazy kitty tell me
no my dear
I'm just a talking cat you have to be
strong don't let them play with your
head oh my kitty I feel completely
broken my chest hurts
oh my dear I'm here for you don't cry I
love you so much
man this is so weird I love you too my
dear we should keep going on now let's
go to the library man there's so many
different things going on hello I got a
password but it was long and a crazy guy
told me so I forgot it
yeah yes I do okay let me remember the
words it was something like your eyes
and ears are limited censors shut them
down before learning good and why is
that oh god aah oh god you if I didn't
ask him why it would have been bad okay
all right then
okay all gone then hey you okay what
hell is that
Oh No uh maybe it's I got a count so
this is one there are two ones
so is it like the Fibonacci sequence so
one one two then it would be it would be
1 then 1 then 2 then 3 so 3 plus 2 is 5
I don't know how to do file I do I have
a book I have a book ok I have a book I
have a book I think it's the Fibonacci
sequence so and Shh that doesn't tell me
much
ok I'm looking for a special book why
are you on ladder oh sorry to ask but
why are you standing on the ladder you
have wings because the ladder was made
to be used of course see what if I need
to use it then you should wait your turn
sassy little girl
Oh what if it's an emergency and I can't
wait that much then you should have
arrived earlier than me sorry but I have
to keep looking and also shut up here
stupid and ugly ok thank you that was an
emotional booster really feel good about
my life now hello sorry to bother you
got there what's wrong and my lady I
don't know let's see what are those
symbols unlock the thimbles are on
numeric system you know one two three oh
I see thank you I'll try again
okay but I don't know which ones all
right can you tell me the right
combination for the lock no myth I can't
I haven't learned that in school yet oh
and what it what is this book you're
reading
it's about two bunny maybe deer and then
three of their friends came over so then
there are five bunnies eating dinner
then carrot you see ah so tells me the
number okay so five is the e looking
thing I'm thinking oh my rabbits ate
dinner looks like they're having fun I
hope they're wow what a beautiful book
yes now I'd like to keep reading please
call okay so I think I know so if this
is 5 and 2 so 5 plus 3 is 8 so probably
this look at thing because 1 you 5 so 8
plus
a plus that would be okay so oh okay so
the one with the the single nipple boob
has to be ten and then the double nipple
boob has to be twenty which means that's
21 this is 8 8 plus 5 is 13 so single
boob plus 3 bada-bing I know the
Fibonacci sequence I'm a genius single
nipple boob and double nipple boob
normal boobs I guess all right so what
did it do
can I do the crank thing ding-dong
damn it okay so what happens if I do
that
ah I won't climb again I could break my
neck if I fall okay
so damn it god damn it there's something
here okay wait hail okay so if I do this
and maybe crank the yank I'll be able to
get what I need not a die
hi you're weird
okay thank you okay then that's weird
I know looks interesting Oh God oh boy
this look looks not fun
why am i helping this crazy old man
again and how is this not going to make
me die okay goodbye then tomorrow
tomorrow I'll probably be dead tomorrow
go away forever please okay so now I
gotta get back to the old man and ease
these errands I'm running for this guy
man it's taken forever
ah man okay but I'm making it I'm making
it I'm making it I'm getting there
cranky to yank don't talk spank hello
did you find the book all right you have
gluten okay I got it
yeah your stupid book so here's your
book it was inside the musical box I saw
that doll Hey the it's word lock that
sounds like fun
that's not his voice thank you for the
book this certainly makes me remember
many things many devious things and now
what there are two things left on the
star yes for fishing the water go
outside and throw it in the river but I
just got it from the river pusher Lamba
Lobo head Robin Abeba who me
fish fish swimming free go back little
fish go home okay
all righty then oh thank you for that
Wow sir you woke up the fish from
deadness yes because I remembered how to
do it I'm a necromancer after all ah
can you do that with other beings like
humans of course but only if the
circumstances are positive what the
circumstances are often not positive I
see sir
hmm so we need to find the missing
stones yes the fish told me that my
shoes are on the feet of an amazing
dancer what huh I think I know
Oh at the show that's right so there's
some like dancing thing at the show but
I can't get in how do I get in the show
I don't know
fine so how the heck am I gonna get any
okay I think yeah okay I had to consult
the walkthrough again but in here's a
hole so the kitty cat can go in there
okay come on kitty go inside and
remember I need to take it to get in so
maybe you can take somebody else's but I
don't want to steal well we'll just
borrow it kitty we can give it back
later or never you know all right cool
steal for me but don't really steal it's
not stealing
mmm all right I'm the cat after all I do
what you say oh oh look at me so where's
this dancer hello hi B hello lady can I
borrow your ticket please because my
ticket disappeared oh I can't oh I can't
I'm using it as a as a hit coaster ah
this lemonade is very good uh but why
you have a table to put the glass on
yeah I don't like the sound of it glass
hits table okay that doesn't make any
sense I see and you like this lemonade
very much right yes Nick and I drink it
because it's refreshing is that insect
playing a trumpet out its butt okay
now if you'll excuse me I want to listen
to the hick music I love my hick musica
there of course goodbye alrighty then
so I gotta find something to use as a
coaster maybe a coin
oh yeah the seasons okay oh look at that
dwell here
okay alright he's an amazing man sir Oh
oh no the B he's direct how was it okay
fine then I got what I needed and that
that that that grasshopper sure can't
move have a ticket I have it you're
incredible kitty it only took you about
three months but that's okay all right
so I'm willing to bet I probably need to
edit the ticket in some way no ma'am
sorry combined no god damn it combined
blah oh salmon ticket to the party I
mean it seems fine
okay all right use it hello look sir it
seems that the ticket has found its way
into my hands what let me see this hmm
it can't be right just can hardly let
someone in with that ticket you bring
many mysteries little lady how can you
know if someone else's ticket the
symbols are correct but look at the
handwriting this belonged to someone
much older than you I can see it let's
see all right then is there any chance I
can get inside I mean it's possible when
you have your own ticket little lady and
no stealing uh how about I yeah can I
and I wait ah-ha-ha-ha-ha what I wanted
to do from the beginning okay alrighty
then haha
ah
okay well I guess I can just watch this
grasshopper dance for a while but I got
what I needed to do and I'm looking at
this amazing dancer how to go through
the seasons hello sir can I have your
shoes hello dancer mister I really need
to take your shoes I'm gonna bash you in
the skull knock you out and steal and
why is this the shoes belong who did
answer I'm a dancer maybe kind of for
now whatever I just need him I'm sorry
what did you just say is he I want your
shoes q5i a little lemonade
you saved me little tense see no sir I
don't want lemonade where did you get
your shoes from you Strickland lemonade
it'll get you drunk okay the great
wizard needs them need your shoes with
museum ah but that's impossible I can't
give you my shoes well I get my shoes to
take them from me
yes you see now I'm standing on them so
it's impossible see but if you lift your
feet I could take them mmm
can't be done not only the very day when
both my feet are up in the air
only then can you take my shoes
otherwise I will stand forever hey stop
that stop that now all right then hello
sir I need your shoes why don't you
answer me please he's concentrating yeah
well if I cut off his legs now grab him
oh boy hello hello would you like an
autograph
what's the trumpeter doing and not
really what's that guy doing playing the
trumpet out of his butt
oh he's bigger than the piano the risen
must be perfect so we can start the show
hi-c thank you so uh oh I know I'm here
in spring ah here we go
okay ooh oh hello ah oh ah there we go
okay a weird color based system but I'm
okay with that okay so if it's going
super fast oh I know okay wait he's just
gonna fix it so I need to unfix it and
then go right to the dancing okay
go go go des SS don't yeah yeah yeah
yeah oh crap and he's dead he just died
he had a poor little heart attack
oh god they dragged him away oh man
okay that was horrifying well at least
check out the shoes that's all that
matters all the matters all the matters
in the whole wide world
alright great wizard I got your blood
shoes I just had to murder a grasshopper
mate it's a little hard explode that's
okay it's alright
why am I getting this wizard this stuff
he seems like a bad guy
sir sir I have the shoes they're very
pretty look wow you did you really have
an extraordinary machine in your head
yeah
thank you sir now let's see the last one
ship Lama from black Blanco oda django
the last one here I recognize this
feather it belongs to petronas paulo
Elantras expect Oh Petronas yes I saw
him he was very injured
he'll be fine ignore it he has the pink
water and can fix anything
yes that's true well what do we do with
the feather go visit the big giant
terrifying doll thing and my wand will
be there hyah
I have to finish my rabbit science when
kitty Winkie ignore my Winx I think I'm
the answer okay sir I'll I'll bring your
wand back you freaking terrifying weirdo
I'm a bad feeling about this I just
generally have a bad feeling about this
I want to mention that very clearly er
okay oh you do have a wound d since when
did you have that so I got to figure out
a way to get the wand to me ah how do I
do that
Tok oh oh cool oh cool I did it
hahaha it was like a game passing around
okay so now I can finally go home
probably not let's go up and see how
this is gonna work out terribly hello I
got your wand it was really easy to do
of all the things that I've done for you
this was probably the easiest I wonder
why is your wand and I wasn't contracted
confront front confronted confronted by
any horrible monstrosity visions
deficits pointed you didn't you stupid
little girl really but where the stones
can I borrow them I can't lend you the
stones the stones are very very special
what I can do is place the stones on the
lock of the door but you you were the
only one who can turn the key and
actually open the door
I see the King told me you would show me
where the door is
ah then we should go talk to him don't
you think wait I suspect that you can't
return home looking like a tree oh I
almost forgot
yes you're right can you bring my human
body back yes I can this is exciting
I haven't done this in a hundred years
let's make a human yes
give me your clothing I need this smell
is no that's fresh this can work we can
make a human I'm freakin weird oh this
is so exciting
hey you're good now go to stand the
fender of the star of a Thursday why I
did this to a twin air one single thing
it did not work out Kevin think about
your body your head your leg and the
other leg maybe your arms while you're
at it poor so would be nice and both of
them concentrate Chimel option sham
Flemish lamb
I'm a big do-si-do I'm a sham I'm
stealing your soul randomly selected
element find your path to your to heaven
become friend Hillman a nail okay oh oh
goodness oh goodness colleague uh-oh it
went wrong what horribly wrong oh okay
maybe you went right huh she's dead now
are you all right Oh what happened is it
done oh wow thank you so much sir you
are a great wizard I think maybe yep my
name right withered because of how great
I am ignore the fact that your entire
back side is still wooden all
whatever now think we have to go the
king now he can show me the door yes huh
I'll be I'll be right there gotta finish
them rabbits science and all that you
wouldn't understand too crazy for a
little girl to comprehend yeah yeah yeah
I'll be there go now okay so well we
have accomplished a lot in a very short
span of time and frankly I feel worse
for wear for doing it so anyway that's
as far as this episode will go thank you
all so much for watching I will get back
to the rest of this game very very soon
so thanks again everybody and as always
I will see you in the next video
uh-huh